please welcome back to our program our
dear friend neil degrasse tyson
and of course our environmental and
lifestyle expert danny theo for another
round of birthday trivia showdown
[Applause]
all right you know the rules each
correct answer is worth one point wait
until i've read the questions and
multiple choice options before you hit
your buzzer and if you answer correctly
you earn a point the contestant with the
most points da wins the coveted earth
day trophy
[Music]
okay number one in the average home
which of the following uses the most
water a flushing the toilet b taking a
10 minute shower or c washing one load
of laundry
yeah i think it's laundry i think
laundry
does that is that your final answer
that's my final answer
danny do you have a different theory
well now he gets the answer out of one
out of two that's true you're right okay
that's fine that's fine that's how this
works i know how math i'm one out of
three i made it easier for him okay
fine
go
i'll take your charity i'm going with
shower
that was correct
[Music]
all right
well wait even with the water restricted
shower nozzles they have today
i'm just saying yeah
that word is a trickle now don't be a
sore loser
all right number two what is the most
reused material in the world a steel b
plastic c
paper
i'm gonna go with steel the same way i'm
gonna steal the second trophy
[Applause]
fun fact in north america we recycle
around 80 million tons of steel each
year from cars and skyscrapers to soup
cans and sardine tins steel is used to
make many of the objects that we
interact with every day cool okay number
three a single mature tree produces
enough error supply for how many people
a year a 10 b
four c
one
neil yeah i'm going with 10.
it is b
oh four oh i don't oh
well i felt bad for giving you that so
i'm just gonna take the lead it's answer
b it's four on average a 50 year old
tree will produce 6 000 pounds of
breathable oxygen in its lifetime number
four which of these household items
cannot be recycled a plastic shower
curtains b fluorescent light bulbs or c
home keys
sharken
the ding means what you mean he's right
he gets the point
the takeaway here is that some plastic
shower curtains are made of pvc also
known as plastic number three which has
toxic chemicals
drew i haven't gotten one right yet
neil there is a lot you do now you went
in there for me all right now there's a
i think there's a lot more in your mind
than shower curtains
just tell you still
try hard and really speedier like meteor
showers all right oh i like that meteor
showers i take meteor showers yes
exactly like that okay all right number
five which of the following takes the
longest time to break down or
disintegrate a disposable
diaper b aluminum can
or c a plastic straw
plastic straw
[Laughter]
this is weird that we spoke of kim
kardashian and skims and diapers because
the answer is a it's a disposable diaper
it takes 500 years for disposable
diapers to degrade creating methane and
other toxic gases in the process
plastic straws take 200 years and
aluminum cans take 250 years
boo to babies
[Applause]
cancel babies
[Laughter]
okay number six how much of the world's
water is available for human use
a 23
b 54
or c one percent
that's one percent clearly yeah yes
yes
only about three percent of earth's
water is fresh water and of that only
one percent can be used as drinking
water the rest or i say potable the rest
is locked up in glaciers ice caps are
buried deep in the ground and most of
our drinking water comes from rivers and
streams um uh
this was if a tiebreaker was needed
to rub it in like that i'm sorry
um
this is cool i'm just fun fact um
what year was the first earth day year
but it happened while we were walking on
the moon in 1970.
i still lose though thank you
that is true congrats
uh today
[Applause]
bye
[Music]